hello everyone we're here at Q con
Barcelona with Matt Moore Matt is one of
the cofounders of K native as well as
GCR the Google container registry Matt
let's talk about GCR in the early days
where did it start
so as around the same time that
kubernetes was starting up and Google
was looking at docker which was
popularizing containers and it became
pretty clear that if we launched a
container service we were gonna need a
way for our customers have really good
integrated experience to ship their
container images to that service right
and so a few of us started to motivate
and build that team and we were tracking
that project seven and kubernetes work
very closely because you know we but we
believed it was going to be a big deal
it's kind of hard to imagine it would
become this big a deal but but yeah like
we we were we were in on the kool-aid
pretty early and yeah it's it's been
amazing to see GCR and kubernetes well
beyond that just become incredibly
successful yeah it is amazing and now
you're involved with a new project Kay
native can you tell us a little bit more
about that sure so so GCR sort of led me
to doing a whole bunch of stuff with
container tools and I've been working
with the LA and our boss Tomas for many
years in the container space and a
couple years ago a year and a half to
two years ago now we we had this sprint
where we we wanted to look at what it
would be like to build sort of
serverless on kubernetes and there was
some early prototyping and and then a
sprint that ultimately led to us
deciding yeah but we're gonna do this
we're gonna do this thing and that
ultimately became ke native cool so what
are some of the biggest challenges that
K native deals with so you know that
they're the three main areas build
surveying and venting I think there are
a lot of things that
we're really hard problems a couple
years ago I think in the build space
some of the stuff that's happened in the
build working group right bill unclutter
builds are seem much more tractable now
than they did a year ago in surveying
you know a scaling as rapidly as a lot
of people expect from serverless cold
starts things like that it's still a
really hard problem and it's gonna be
one of those things that zero zero
milliseconds startups aren't gonna be
fast enough for some people right so so
it's gonna be one of these things that
we're gonna have to invest in forever
just like kubernetes on scale right and
then eventing right like they're they're
gonna be there's gonna be an endless
source of sources where people are gonna
want to be like when that happens you
know I want to do something right and so
yeah so it's there are these interesting
and huge problems and then even just you
know organizationally how are we going
to manage the complexity of all of these
things over time so a lot of interesting
challenges cool so what is the current
status of the Kay native project and
what are the features that you're
excited about so we just cut point six I
think lost Tuesday and there it is my
favorite released so far we launched
sort of the beginnings of our beta API
there and we hope that that will be a
near final API shape that we can take
through 2v1
and a bunch of other really cool
features launched like Auto TLS and some
other things that allow you to get you
know a really good experience all the
way through to a TLS terminated URL with
little to no work on the developer side
once an operator has sort of set things
up for you sort of looking at that core
of functionality that we've been really
iterating on so far we want to get that
to GA and then we can start to look at
iterating on improving some of the stuff
around scale performance and as well as
starting to get into the rhythm of a
sort of future track releases for new
stuff right there's always new stuff now
you have a managed version by Google
called cloud run of K Natives why amen
solution so you know as with kubernetes
and it's the right like get it getting
things set up just right isn't always
the easiest thing in the world and I
think you know Kelsey has a great
kubernetes of the hard way right
we thankfully it's not that hard because
goober nice done a lot to get that set
up but you know you know I mentioned DNS
and TLS right getting that set up just
right on the cluster is pretty hard and
you know we we want the manage service
to make that the out of box experience
really easy so that you can focus on the
things that you actually want to focus
on and not the you know the boring stuff
right but we want to solve the boring
stuff for you nice so let folks focus on
the problems that they care about rather
than the infrastructure that's awesome
so last question we're here at Q Khan
this is the biggest Q con so far what
are you excited about seeing this week I
think the most surreal thing has been
like you know you walk around and when
you hear people talking about this
project that you've helped the start and
they don't realize you're there and
that's pretty cool and seeing product
announcements like the rancher
announcement I think yesterday or today
where they're launching things based on
a native that you know you didn't even
know about it's good great it's really
cool to see those things but honestly
one of my favorite things to do here is
to talk to all of the vendors that are
here at the booths and you know see what
they're doing and find ways to
collaborate and help build the community
that's definitely one of my favorite
things to do and connect with
contributors who I feel like I know
really really well but I'm meeting for
the first time in person there's a few
of them that I've just met for the first
time this week and yeah it's they're
great people and I love working with
them thank you so much for your time
[Music]